there's apparently no end to the
surprises good and bad when it comes to
Donald Trump the latest of these is his
peace summit with North Korean leader
Kim jong-un
where the two leaders declared a new era
of good relations between their
countries
Trump's zero casualty enforcement of a
red line in Syria and continued economic
growth at home should have given us
pause for thought
but this summit in Singapore has been
unprecedented bringing us back from
potential nuclear disaster now I've been
no Trump fan but as outrageous as he can
be let's not kid ourselves if any other
American president especially Bill
Clinton or Barack Obama and achieve what
Trump just pulled off with the little
rocket man they would be hailed by our
fellow liberals as statesmen it is
disingenuous to pretend otherwise
and if being liberal means avoiding
alternative facts it is time for us all
to give credit to Trump where credit is
due
lest we become precisely like the
dogmatic ideologues we hold in such
disdain a stranger I did say he was out
right I'm gonna take inspiration from
your subject matter and go a little bit
off piste
oh really ask your personal question
sure sure how many times the day do you
pee
I thought they do you pray I'm meant to
pray five times ago no but I imagine
quite a few times to keep myself - peeve
six times a day and that was the same
number of times as the average number of
lies Donald Trump tells ok every day yes
I'm trying to make is you can flip this
yeah imagine if Obama had told six lies
every day blowing tires I think he did
do you think that that would have been
tolerated by the American people can you
imagine if can you imagine if Obama was
accused of sorting with us and then
lying about it and then lying about the
conch believe this is all you know the
point I'm trying to make Majid is you're
saying that it's it's hypocrisy because
the liberal liberals would that won't
give Trump the same even armor for what
he's accomplished I'm still vote for
Obama over trophy
is it you want to get away with a flirty
one let's have a look at his handshake
and I'll tell you why I think I disagree
with you this look at this look at this
right now here we have the two men
shaking hands this is historically
unprecedented nobody ever dreamed such a
thing could have ever happened and by
the way it was Obama's outgoing outgoing
requests to President Trump to avoid a
nuclear deal disaster with North Korea
see even Obama wanted to make sure that
this happened what we're seeing right
there and here's why I disagree with you
because do you remember the nuclear deal
Obama made with Iran yeah
now that the same criticisms that are
now being levied against Trump for
legitimizing a tyrannical regime and
allowing them to get off scot-free when
the nuclear arms are the same criticisms
that were made against Obama by
conservatives and liberals were
defending Obama then when he made that
deal with Iran I supported both deals
the only problem now with the Iranian
deal is of course that cachet of files
that have been found that proves that
the Iranian zactly stored all the
information as to how to make nuclear
weapons as opposed to eliminating them
as they should have done but in
principle I support peace deals wherever
they're made and I just think we all
need to be a bit more consistent let me
reply quickly no seriously what let me
like what yeah I agree with you if Trump
can achieve denuclearization with North
Korea he will deserve to be praised for
that we all want a safer world right my
issue is not and I of course have
problems about doing deals with one of
the most human rights abusing regimes
the world but we need D nuclearization
how will he achieve denuclearization we
don't have the details and there are
issues about the way he's run it
alienated from his allies well I for if
I can refer to something slightly more
robust than Maajid Nawaz is toilet
habits which would be this morning's
Financial Times which one for you like
you've enjoyed enjoyed reading over your
breakfast and it talks about the success
that Trump has done the top half that
one is about the success he's achieved
in Korea taking on board we still have
the devil in the detail and then it also
talks about another point the US
economy's accelerating growth rapid job
creation but of course after you are
with all the other lovers across the
whole of the world and possibly the
chief the Lavi in chief or the keep the
key cheerleader I refer to none other
than of course Robert De Niro
the Tony Awards earlier this week I'm
gonna say one thing Trump
it's no longer down with trumpets trunk
a couple of points and then I'll yield
how brave it is to tell an audience from
Hollywood on the screen to start
shouting about Trump that really took
some courage didn't it I wonder I wonder
if you live in Los Angeles whether to
pick him at a point that Majid made and
you've been watching TV did you feel
more secure by images of the leader of
the Western world and your president
shaking hands with the first North
Korean leader ever 70 years since the
Korean War seeing those pictures in
thinking oh or were you more comforted
by an aging actor screaming four-letter
words at a Hollywood Sirte Tony's
ceremony I wonder which gave you more
comfort and you bring in Barack Obama
and my final point you would have been
among those who when Barack Obama gave a
speech to our president in Prague and he
talked about I see a world without
nuclear weapons and he got a Nobel Peace
Prize and people said we need to give
him another award and people fell and
swooned that very night North Korea did
some nuclear tests that very night
how did Barack Obama respond he warned
Kim jong-un he could be isolated oh boy
let's do it the Trump way you're a
rocket man if you come after me I will
unleash the forces of hell it's worked
I actually was among those who thought
that Obama shouldn't have been awarded
the Peace Prize because they hadn't done
anything yet just because Nick said that
that's what kind of thing I would become
we put this in a wider context which is
that President Trump left the g7 summit
having invited Russia back in having
dumped on the America's closest ally
Canada and saying that there was a
special place in hell reserved for
Justin Trudeau everything he has done
recently appears as if he's taking
dictation from the Kremlin from
resigning from the Iran nuclear deal
which of course sent the oil price up
which means that Russia is sitting
pretty with oil $80 no no no just wait
for it I'm not judging your point it's
do you really feel safer with Donald
Trump in the White House whatever he did
with Kim jong-un can I just make one
point he removed from the communique of
the after the g7 that hopeless g7 summit
that we'd you know we were basically
these countries the powerful coalition
were in favor of the rules-based
international order he
he prefers to freelancing during trade
doing deals with other dictators
basically so let's hear what Donald Tusk
had to say about this yeah the
rules-based international order is being
challenged quite surprisingly not by the
usual suspects but by its main architect
and guarantor the u.s. at the same time
you will not stop trying to convince our
American friends and President Trump
that undermining this order makes no
sense at all well it happens to be the
president's 72nd birthday this week
today's Thursday so what you say is a
nice little birthday surprise for him as
was his nomination by two Norwegians for
the Nobel Peace Prize look I mean the
proof in the pudding is going to be the
in the eating and let's see what the
communique says if he has brought peace
in our time only in the Korean Peninsula
and if he has we need to acknowledge it
Michelle I couldn't care less how often
you go to toilet I don't want to even
think about you on the toilet quite
frankly but I do agree with everything
that you've just said and I think that
there are a great number of people that
no matter what Donald Trump does he
could do the most amazing a positive
thing in the world they still would not
be able to find it within themselves to
give him credit and you said yeah but
like you just said that Obama couldn't
get away with a lot of the stuff that
Donald Trump did Donald Trump don't
really get away with anything people are
on his back on his case what he said
during his campaign I could stand on in
the middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot
someone in broad daylight and I'd still
win this election but that was just him
being a bit stupid because ultimately
what happened with Donald Trump is that
a lot but a lot of people well it's
somebody different and they're voting
for him based on the things that he was
promising and actually what you've got
is you've got somebody that's for one
starting to deliver on what they said
that they would deliver and that it's
actually quite refreshing look I'm a
trompe critic okay and I've been so
before his election all I'm trying to
say is where the evidence points us we
should as liberals being evidence led
that's what we pride ourselves on and I
think that for example in
forcing a red line in Syria is something
Obama didn't do and Trump did do with
zero casualties I think the performance
of the economy and now North Korea are
all that they're all things in his favor
and of course the g7 and the trade stuff
is against him as is his general bombast
bigotry